- Mr. Williams, you
reportedly came in last night
'cause your--
- My watch was stolen.
- Your watch was stolen while on you.
So you were mugged?
- Yes.
- Can you tell us, take us
through again what happened?
- Yeah, basically I
was just on my way home
from work last night.
And I was waiting for the train.
And this guy came up.
I think he had a weapon,
I think he had a gun,
and he just, he took my watch.
- And I just, I need to--
- [Lady] Yeah, yeah.
- When you put a watch on
like that, a flashy watch,
who are you really wearing it for?
(saxophone music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
Look, I hate to say it but
you just need to be more self-aware
that when you wear a watch out like that,
you're really just taunting people.
- It's in our human nature
to want to grab after wealth.
And so a man strutting
around with expensive things,
it's taunting.
Men just can't dress nice
when the sun goes down.
- Men generally shouldn't
wear a major brand label
after dusk, really.
I have two sons of my own at home.
And I would never let them
out of the house after 7pm
in anything other than sweatpants.
- Yeah.
You need to dress down.
- Mr. Williams, were you drinking
the night that this happened?
- No, I just got off work.
- Do you like to drink?
Couple after work?
Couple on weekend?
- Did you try to disguise it?
Is there a chance that
perhaps you gave the man
an idea that maybe you wanted him to come
look at the watch?
- Maybe you're putting
off a vibe that said,
"Hey, look at this watch."
(saxophone music)
The manner in which you were walking,
would you say that you
were flashing the watch?
- I wouldn't say that.
- Maybe one could even say that you were
advertising the watch.
- Wait, can we just focus more
on the guy that mugged me?
- Advertising the watch.
- Listen, man, I wasn't
doing anything illegal.
I was walking down the street.
The guy that mugged me, that's illegal.
- My sons are in sweatpants every day.
(saxophone music)